[Musique]
crypto parle de désir et de beauté
incarnée dans une créature mythique une
créature qui bouleverse la vie d'un
couple en perte de vitesse
l'homme et la femme en tombe amoureux
ils font appel à un chirurgien plastique
pour lui donner une forme humaine
criquetot raconte cette métamorphose et
son impact sur le couple j'adore les
danses narrative à les quelque chose qui
raconte une histoire j'adore les
histoires mais il ya quelque chose qui
est intéressant dans le processus que
ces quatre personnes quand même le show
c'est seulement 4 personnes 4
personnages et à vraiment gros
cheminement côté côté caractère
personnage
guillaume côté s'est entouré d'artistes
talentueux venus de partout dans le
monde pour créer cette oeuvre d'une
esthétique remarquable notamment avec
des vidéos effets visuels
le danseur a été inspiré par son travail
auprès de robert lepage
quand ils ont créé ensemble le spectacle
french by frame l'an dernier à toronto
la chose la plus importante qui est
resté avec moi de robert c'est que c'est
pas à propos des du multimédia ou des
québec où c'est pas propos de tout ça
c'est juste ces choses là s'ils sont
bien utilisés peuvent vraiment accentuer
la façon de raconter notre histoire de
défaut c'est la façon de monter un
spectacle avec une façon différente de
voir les choses
crypto est la première production
indépendante de guillaume côté réalisée
en parallèle à sa carrière de danseur
étoile et chorégraphe au ballet national
du canada
c'est un saut dans le vide parce que
j'avais pas c'est toute la musique et
original toutes les
les saints c'est original tout les taux
dans le fond on a commencé de rien avec
vraiment des idées fans scratch alors ça
c'est un gros défi c'est toujours de
prendre la danse et le ballet en général
et j'essaie de j'essaie de mettre aucune
limite
[Musique]
crypto est appelée à évoluer au fil des
représentations
plusieurs dates sont prévues au québec
au cours des prochains mois ainsi qu'à
toronto et guillaume côté et compte bien
présenter sa création
ailleurs dans le monde ici catherine
françois radio-canada saint sauveur